à
en
il m'arrive un truc set mais je crois
qu'on m'a drug use
je me souviens de rien je me suis
réveillé les cicatrices
les voleurs je crois est magnifique la
cicatrice si demain c'est un cador ton
chien justement d'aller remettre la main
dessus à cela pourquoi est-ce que tu
gardes ton dix heures tu arrives là tout
de suite au japon avait surtout beaucoup
je vais prendre la même chose qui est
fière désolé on vous a jamais vu ici
cette infâme qu'est ce que l'on dit dans
tout ça ça m'a fait chier
le seigneur nous a dit on mais plus de
plaisir à donner qu'à recevoir
j'ai vraiment tout pensé pour la grèce
un jour j'aimerais que vous expliquer
réellement pourquoi ces petites affiches
ça s'est passé en une activité
je vais le retrouver